mostrar un pase sanitario para tomar el
transporte público este es el gesto que
deben tener los italianos desde esta
mañana una medida que divide a la
opinión pública
pero para mí es algo bueno estoy
totalmente de acuerdo con estas
restricciones es la única manera de
salir de esta situación
honestamente tengo que sinceramente creo
que el super base sanitario no es eficaz
contra el virus la fijamos a la lucha
contra este virus creo que la gente
debería ser libre de vacunarse si
quieres la iata libre era la siesta de
la persona
las autoridades italianas han endurecido
las restricciones en el país además de
la tarjeta sanitaria necesaria para el
transporte han introducido una super
tarjeta sanitaria que permite el acceso
a bares restaurantes cine teatros y
discotecas a este pase solo pueden
acceder las personas que se han vacunado
o curado el coronavirus una forma de
animar a los italianos reacios a
vacunarse pero que podría repercutir en
los propietarios de bares el
super pase sanitario es contradictorio y
restrictivo restrictivo porque no
permite a las personas con un test pcr
negativo ir a restaurantes y bares me
contradictorio porque pueden hacer sus
compras así que no le veo el sentido se
han solicitado estas medidas estarán en
vigor hasta el 15 de enero a menos que
la situación empeore en los últimos días
se han registrado entre 15.000 y 20.000
casos diarios casi 85% de las personas
mayores de 12 años están totalmente
vacunadas roma- también se está
preparando para dar paso a la vacunación
de los niños de 5 a 11 años